finally i get to make this video i've
seen this video being made by many many
tech youtubers and um finally i can make
it because it's been exactly 10 years
that i've been coding
which means from 2012
to
2022 today
so i thought by the time i finished
making this video it would be 2022 so
that's why i pretended as if it were
already 2022.
sorry um also i just want to note that
i know a lot of you might use this video
as a playbook for what classes to take
what side projects to do or what
companies to work for
don't i mean everyone's path is
different even if you've been working at
a different industry and you don't have
a cs degree like me it doesn't mean you
can't get into tech this portion of the
video is sponsored by growth google like
which is why i want to talk about growth
google and their google career
certificate which is the sponsor of
today's video
i truly believe in what they're doing i
finally found online courses that really
teach you real world skills that you
actually use on the job i mean it's
taught by google so the quality is
really high plus you actually get a
certificate that is recognized by top
employers including google of course
whether it's in data analytics ux design
or project management they have a course
for that and a certificate to put on
your resume to show your future
employers i took a look at their data
analytics course since i was once a data
scientist myself and i have to say their
course on coursera really teaches you
the stuff you need to know to be well
equipped on the job the course is very
comprehensive so even if you have no
relevant experience you can go at your
own pace and learn everything you need
honestly i think it would have helped a
lot for me as well since they use the
tools that i use that work like sql
tableau and r if you're thinking of
learning a new skill or you want to
start or advance your career check out
grow.google
certificates that portion of the video
was sponsored by growth google now back
to the video
year 2012 the year of initiation i
joined the robotics club in school where
we had to build a robot to compete in a
competition called crc i was not a big
fan of manual labor because
using any hand tools would potentially
break my beautiful nails so that was out
of the question there was only one thing
left for me programming the robot's
brain now
i didn't even know what programming was
back then i just read the instructions
and tried to make it work so that we can
control our robot with the joystick
what i used to do that was their own
simplified language called robot c
of course our team won the whole thing
the whole competition but that's also
because we were competing against 14
year olds
and we were 19 at the time so 2012 was
also the year i started college at
university of waterloo and i took my
first cs course called designing
functional programs so i wrote code like
this no loops no variables but lots of
recursion so what i learned
no one is too dumb for computer science
year 2013.
in 2013 i became a finance wannabe you
have to pronounce it finance not finance
so i was a finance wannabe freshman year
is the year of doing things just to pad
your pitiful resume
you know it i know it no need to lie to
me
my best work experience at this point so
far mcdonald's where i handled
concurrent micro transactions in a
fast-paced environment
so clearly i had to start a side project
and coincidentally i built something
that handled concurrent transactions in
a high speed environment
like i made a trading bot
the site had people betting on events
like whether the gold price would reach
x amount by the end of the week and you
know most people did it for fun and
games but i had to ruin their fun by
actually mathematically modeling the
statistical likelihood of the outcome
and bet on that
i sound smart right
not really i just copied a wikipedia
article because there's a formula
and that's it that's all i did
so did i make money
yes was it luck
absolutely i never even hedged my
positions
now back in university i took elementary
algorithm design and data something like
that where i learned about linked lists
for the first time
and object-oriented programming i took
that course where i learned how to
finally organize my code in classes and
then also i took the class called logic
and computation which i learned
absolutely nothing
all that jazz helped me land an
internship at scotiabank
doing what you guessed it automating
option pricing with black shoals model
if that means nothing to you don't worry
it doesn't mean anything to me too
just buzz words
if you do understand good job
no one asked
what i learned you can't rely on others
to just hand you things if you want
something worth getting you'll have to
be proactive or else everyone else would
also have it then
year 2014
computer literacy
this was the year of demystifying
computers i took data structures and
data management aka how to lead code
which is great because i probably
wouldn't be able to get my next
internship
without it if it wasn't for that course
and that next internship was citadel
and holy cow did i learn a lot at
citadel uh because because i was
clueless right for some reason i had to
build web servers from scratch in c plus
i had to implement websockets from
scratch meaning i had to construct the
data frames with like op codes and stuff
i was so lost at first my manager just
gave me a networking textbook and an os
textbook so i just learned enough
just enough to complete my project right
so tcp udp bit manipulation logs and
currency all just to implement some
server and a web interface to display
tiny numbers quickly for traders who
barely look at them
what i learned finally understood how a
simple text file can turn into a program
how bits turn into data and how programs
turn into production ready software
year 2015 that year i finally became a
silicon valley baby boy by landing an
internship at linkedin
while i was there i wrote some c plus
code that never got deployed and i quote
from
your code was not only useless but it
was toxic it held back our team for a
whole quarter
anyways i got a return offer and a
stellar review great experience five out
of five would do it again
after the internship
i decided to do some research assistant
work for my favorite operating system
professor
i even got my face to be on the paper
totally undeserved so i was sick of
doing the same thing
so i wanted to try some data science so
i went to intern at facebook i learned
sql i learned how to make pretty graphs
i touched mark zuckerberg's hand
and then he put me on a blacklist
um
yeah that's it
basically i
don't think i coded at all
maybe a little bit of python scripting
but mostly just sql stuff
it was quite refreshing actually
what i learned
anything is learnable nothing is out of
reach as long as you just sit down be
patient and read from the beginning
i never did distributed systems low
latency networking i never did data
analytics
but i just learned
year 2016
rebellion
ah
senior year i took one of the hardest
courses in our school apparently it was
called computer graphics
it wasn't that hard conceptually
it was just a lot of work basically
during the whole course i rendered so
many pictures of balls and more balls
and balls of different colors balls of
different transparency levels
balls of different glossiness
i made dragon balls
so my last internship
was at microsoft
they promised it would be a product
management type job but i ended up just
prototyping windows server security
products using powershell
what i learned
absolutely nothing
nothing
year 2017
passion meets career
so i was on track
to getting a prosperous career in tech
with my resume but somehow between 2016
and 2017
something went terribly wrong and i
suddenly wanted to become a youtuber
so i worked at buzzfeed as a data
scientist hoping that i can appear in
some of their videos
my actual job was to try to understand
facebook videos and how to grow their
facebook pages but at some point they
told me i should stop trying to appear
in so many videos
then i became depressed
because it didn't make me famous
anyway after that
i decided to go back to facebook
as a data scientist telling myself that
i will never do youtube again funny how
life works because i did join the
facebook's video creator team
so that was cool
and also
that's when my youtube channel blew up
what i learned
the things you learn and the skills you
gain that are completely unrelated to
each other
often actually complement each other
surprisingly
like for example my obsession with
videos helped me understand the facebook
video platform intimately as a data
scientist
which helped my job
year 2018 burnout
i really enjoyed working at facebook
because it was related to videos i live
and breathe video platforms that's me
but i was also growing on youtube
a lot
so my focus was split you know i i
didn't stop to think about what i really
wanted in life
i just did things grew my channel chased
numbers and got burnt out
i didn't quote a single line as a data
scientist
so nothing there
what i learned
one of the best skills to work on in
your life is the ability to be
self-aware and understand yourself
just like coding sports or video games
it all comes down to practice the more
you work on trying to understand
yourself the more you'll be literate in
your own emotions
and having that understanding of
yourself will allow you to make way
better decisions
year 2019 rebirth
so i needed to press reset on my life
and think about what kind of life i
wanted to live
i wanted to chill
so i chose to be a software engineer
i was scared um i haven't coded in so
long and my last software job was in
2015 right my last internship at
linkedin
so i did the typical lee code grind huge
imposter syndrome
applied to two big companies got
extremely lucky and got both offers
i was so so relieved so much of my
mental health quickly got better
basically
year 2020 disillusionment
i never worked as a software engineer
full-time
so i thought i would have to really work
hard to play catch-up
but then i learned that everyone else
was as clueless as i was coincidentally
once again i was mostly working in c
plus
same thing every time i know i did a lot
of infra work even though i was in a
product team but i also did a lot of
analysis as well because it was a
product team so you had to do analysis
to kind of justify your projects
to see if it's even worth pursuing
so for stuff like that
the fact that i came from facebook as a
data scientist
it really came in handy and and also my
presentations were always
beautiful because i used to be a data
scientist
what i learned
in the end work is just work your
technical abilities and your expertise
don't matter as much as you think what
matters more is your grit
and just if you can get stuff done
so just be a doer and make things you're
proud of and the rest will come
coding youtube filmmaking it doesn't
matter they're all the same
you're building something
year 2021
moving on
this year my youtube channel became
pretty
big
i can't really call it a hobby anymore
but the crazy thing is
i'm loving it more than ever before
and the craziest thing is
i wanted to be a youtuber when i was
like 15
and it actually came true
i am so grateful that i have this
youtube channel
it gives me so much flexibility allows
me to express myself creatively
and it gives me access to some pretty
impressive people in the tech world
all because i make silly videos on the
internet right
it's crazy to think that i probably
wouldn't have made it as a youtuber if
it weren't for my coding videos
if it weren't for me being a programmer
so i got really really lucky i am very
lucky
but i also worked hard
so what i've learned
there are lots of ways to be successful
and also success is defined differently
for everyone
a good rule of thumb
is to pursue projects and opportunities
that you can learn from
that you can grow from
because in the end successful outcomes
are pretty much luck
so if you want to succeed it's a numbers
game like rolling the dice
so keep rolling the dice you can't
control the outcomes of your dice rolls
but you can control what dice you use
and the more you work on yourself the
more the dice become weighted to your
advantage
so eventually you'll hit jackpot as long
as you keep rolling the dice
you'll achieve success whatever that
means
for you specifically
anyways that's it for the video
see ya